people can't get enough of the Clown
Prince of Crime at least that's what
Warner Brothers seems to think now that
news has emerged that not one but two
solo movies for the character being
developed it's a move that raises a lot
of questions for the casual movie goer
its Jared Leto still the Joker or are we
getting Joaquin Phoenix and if they're
both the Joker how we've got the answers
to all this and more so if you're
wondering why everything seems to be
coming up Joker stay with us developing
DC Warner Brothers DC extended universe
is a movie series that's hard to talk
about without bringing up comparisons to
Marvel launched in 2013 with Man of
Steel the DC EU is a direct response to
the success that Marvel Studios and
Disney have been having with their
Cinematic Universe since the release of
Iron Man in 2008 big differences have
emerged in the way we learn about
upcoming movies in each franchise
regarding Marvel we generally don't know
what they're working on
until they officially announce something
meaning that by the time we hear about a
movie that they're doing we can be
fairly confident it's actually going to
happen
DC takes the opposite approach with
leaks and rumors emerging about a
downright confusing number of movies and
development some of which more than
likely will never see the light of day
it's almost too much to keep track of
making things extra confusing for the
casual fan there's been talk of like the
Harley Joker film and the Gotham City
sirens are those two distinct things
they're talking about the sirens project
no it's a totally separate one the joke
book let's talk about the DC movies just
related to the Joker in order of how
likely they seem to actually happen
first off they're Suicide Squad 2 which
is reportedly set to feature Jared Leto
returning to the role as part of an
ensemble next there is the most recently
announced Joker solo movie also set the
center on Leto's Joker
then there's the biggest wild card of
all the Martin Scorsese produced todd
phillips directed joaquin phoenix led
Joker origin movie finally there's the
twisted romantic comedy project
featuring Harley Quinn and the Joker
supposedly this movie replaces the
Gotham City sirens movie we've heard so
many reports about which also was
reportedly going to involve Leto's Joker
in other words Warner Brothers could be
currently working on no less than four
different
involving the Joker two of them solo
movies with completely different actors
the obvious question is how the joaquin
phoenix movie could possibly fit in with
the tone established by Leto's Joker
much less the continuity of the DC EU
the answer is simple they won't
Elseworlds
even before justice league saw a
theatrical release word was out that
Warner Brothers was in the process of
re-evaluating its strategy regarding DC
Comics movies specifically the studio
started exploring the possibility that
this whole shared universe thing might
not be all it's cracked up to be
they'd hardly be the only ones to screw
up a movie mega verse
word is Warner Brothers is in the
process of creating a new banner for
movies to take place outside of shared
universe continuity under this
arrangement multiple actors will be able
to play the same role with anything that
happens outside the shared universe
being irrelevant to it that way any
actor will be able to play the Joker on
the big screen in an alternate universe
story having no effect on the storyline
of Jared Leto's Joker it works for DC's
animated universe
so why not the big screen for now this
separate banner remains untitled and
Warner Brothers hasn't done a whole lot
to make the general public aware that
they're making this move leaving the
door open for what feels like an
unnecessary amount of confusion joke in
Phoenix so what is this alternate
universe Elseworlds style joker movie
here's what we know right now according
to reports DC is developing a solo Joker
origin story starring Joaquin Phoenix
directed by Todd Phillips of the
hangover series Fame Phillips is
co-writing the script with Scott silver
who wrote eight-mile and the fighter the
movie is being produced in part by
Martin Scorsese and at this point
there's every indication that Phoenix
really has signed on for the role though
he's publicly been cagey about his
involvement so far a lot of the
information that we have about the
movie's premise comes from anime fighter
turned comedian Brendan Schaub who
spilled some showbiz gossip during an
appearance on the Joe Rogan experience
podcast as a kid she had it like a
permit smile and everyone made fun of
them and it's like on the streets of
Brooklyn it's like super dark real I
can't wait
Joker Joker story right now not much is
known about Jared Leto's Joker movie the
hunt is currently on for a director and
a screenwriter and it's unknown whether
the movie will be produced before or
after Suicide Squad - either way the
earliest we'll see this is in 2019 as
for the plot well it probably won't be
an origin story Leto going forward with
the movie would seem to indicate that
any bad blood that may have existed
between him and Warner Brothers has more
or less dissolved if you'll recall Leto
seemed pretty peeved at the way his
Suicide Squad work was treated in the
editing room with most of his involved
performance ending up on the cutting
room floor
Elseworlds apart if the Elseworlds
style banner takes off there are many
stories in DC's stable that might get
adaptations one potential project Warner
Brothers was once considering is
Superman red Sun a story that imagines
how things might have shaken out had the
Kryptonian crash-landed in the USSR as a
story it's the perfect example of what
this alternate world movie banner could
accomplish making multiple Joker films
may sound like the strangest way to
start it but if Warner Brothers hits on
something it could very well
revolutionize the way Studios approach
comic book movies maybe it's time to go
to the next level and wouldn't it be
funny if DC was the one who leads us
there despite the mistakes of even the
rather recent past it could work out for
everyone and that's no joke thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]